okay
Cliffhanger there
all right everyone
um happy to be here I'm excited for
today's uh for the today's talk
um first of all thanks for operators for
hosting this event and now it
are you serious
okay it works I'm not touching it I feel
you a little bit
um yeah thanks for potatoes for hosting
this event and thanks for pi data for
having me
um it's actually my first Pi data
conference and then as speaker so it's
an honor to be here and the topic for
today is is Lang chain which is an LM
framework which you can uh like you can
good get the full potential of llms out
of out of llms with LinkedIn and yeah
but before I start I'd like to introduce
myself
um this is me and this is my picture and
here are some facts about me I studied
mechatronics originally at hoshulu
Mannheim and I focused on artificial
intelligence in my in my masters and
originally I worked in the CV area so I
did a lot of pedestrian detection with
Lida and radar data and this was also my
Master's thesis and yeah originally I
wanted to to do a PhD afterwards but I
then I I got stuck in a building
building stuff with with value and this
is why I don't knocks because I saw
so great potential in the in the company
and in the e-commerce in the e-commerce
bubble as I say and especially with with
llms which I work nowadays mostly
um yeah and it's a lot of fun it's an
it's an open playground for for AI and
this is why I'm excited about it and
yeah
some some person some facts about me my
free time I'm a Triumph lead I do a lot
of swimming cycling and running yeah
so far so good about me
okay this is our roadmap for today uh
first I'm going to give a small
introduction uh what Langton is and why
you guys should use it and why you
should play around with it then I'll
present some some features of link chain
which I think give the most value
um for for companies or for your
personal fun or your personal interests
and then I'll provide some example
applications which we use at snog soul
and which I think every company can use
to to leverage llms then I give a short
summary and then we'll have the Q a
all right let's get right into it
um what is link chain and why should you
use it
basically link chain is a framework
which makes the work with llms with
large language models way easier so it's
it basically you can think about Lang
chain as a connection between the llms
and the outside sources which could be
Google which could be Wikipedia which
could be your own docs which could be
like notion and yeah basically it makes
the the connection between these two
parts or these these two sources way way
easier
how does an application including
language chain look like you have you
would have a normal front end could be
like streamlit or it could be a normal
react front end which we have at snox
and then you have the Lang chain
framework or the link chain application
um between the the front end and the
large language models and basically
every function in Lang chain
is to to make the
llms more accessible
right then one could say why did I not
simply use the open API and that's
basically a valid question because the
API is just fine you can you can use it
for a simple prompt for simple prompts
and I think every one of you has
prompted GPT before and this is the same
with with the API if you have a simple
input output problem then just use the
the open API but I'm going to
demonstrate in a second where the value
of link chain is with a simple uh with a
simple example and then you'll see why
link chain is is so good and why I'm so
excited about it
okay let's switch
okay
can you see that yeah nice okay I've
I've prepared a little uh Jupiter
notebook for for every feature I'm going
to I'm going to present uh in the first
um
what is it called I don't know in the
first cell nice English
um you you have the basic Imports and
then
um
am I in the right I'm not in the right
notebook I'm sorry
um basic Imports like I said and then
this is what you would do for the normal
uh GPT API or GPT API with a little help
helper function which is called chat and
then you return the response and of
course this is not too complicated and
it works just fine like I said for the
for the simple question tell a joke for
AI scientists it works just fine
and uh this talk is uh pretty bad so
let's move on
and uh this and in Langton in a nutshell
is uh that is just way less complicated
so you can see you can do the same thing
in just two lines of code so and of
course you could argue okay why does
this provide value but you can imagine
the more complicated the problem gets
the more value Lang chain can give and
this is what I want to demonstrate in
this in this presentation
okay
then let's jump back into the
presentation
you can see it again right yeah
okay
features of Lang chain
um there are a lot of features
um too many to to handle in this
presentation this is why I want to focus
on prompts and how Langston handles
prompts because I think that's a pretty
good touch point because everyone has
prompted for for GPT and this is a good
entry point I want to talk about chains
agents and Company combinations with
tools and then the vector store
integration of link chain
okay let's start with prompts and uh
yeah like I said for basic prompts just
use the API and but for more complex
prompts or even Dynamic prompts
langstain provides a lot of tool sets
which make the the work just just a lot
easier which I'm gonna demonstrate in
another example which I prepared for
today
let's see
here we go now we go into this now
that's that's the right one okay this is
basically after the the normal Imports
this is basically the same thing which
you did before we Define a prompt and
this time it's in e-commerce because I'm
I'm biased I have to use e-commerce
examples
um
um so here you can see we should write a
product description for Boxer shots from
snocks on Amazon and yeah after a short
waiting time and this is what the alarm
provides it's not important that right
not that important right now but this is
where it gets interesting and you can
believe me if you would do a dynamic
prompting with with uh
with standard strings and standard
variables it gets messy pretty fast and
you can see we have four input variables
so we have the text type product brand
and Marketplace and we can dynamically
access these with the template and the
prompt template which we which which we
get from the template and then all we
can do or all we have to do is Define
our text types products in lists Brands
Marketplace and so on and loop through
them I'm not going to run this right now
because it's a
it's expensive and it takes some time
that's the that's a bigger problem right
now and then you can iterate iteratively
just produce a lot of text really fast
and it's not that complicated it's just
these three lines of code and I think
that's pretty amazing and we use that
all the time when building our our tools
um yeah that's I think a good entry
point on why link chain provides so much
value at least for us
okay
so fast or good let's jump back
to the presentation
here we go
okay next I'm gonna talk about chains
I'm only going to talk about LM chains
because I haven't worked with the other
chains there are a lot of chain
variations in in Lang chain but I only
have worked with the llm ones and I
don't want to talk here about anything I
don't know so that's why I'm going to
stick to LM chains and a chain is
basically a wrapper around different
components of Lang chain and because
there's
um
what does it mean it means basically
that you have you're combining different
LM calls and actions automatically so
I'm going to demonstrate that in another
example
here we go
so imagine a world where you have to
give a high data talk in one week's time
and you have no idea what to talk about
apart from an introduction a structure
which you have gotten from tpd
definitely didn't happen for me and uh
yeah then I thought I I could build
something with the with the chain which
helps me out on that so I have my basic
structure here and uh
then what I do is I put it into a
template and I provide the template or I
give the template the structure and uh
then I yeah that's what I what I did
before I create an llm I
um created from template and then I
created an llm chain and this LM chain
gets in llm and a prompt template and
the output key is Improvement so
basically what it does it gives me
Improvement uh recommendations for my
structure so this is the first part of
the chain and the second part of the
sequential chain will be another llm and
another template
and another chain also which takes these
Improvement recommendations and puts
them into my structure so it implements
them into the structure and this is how
you can can optimize Concepts really
fast and we at stocks have a tool which
which creates concepts for us with with
Dynamic inputs we which we can choose I
think that's pretty amazing and this is
a light open source version of that and
what I do next
is I I put the two chains into the
sequential chain object and
there then the two chains run after each
other so and then I uh I run them in a
loop and then as you can see it goes
through the iterations and then in the
end I get the the better or better
structure
so
um and you can like extend that I'm
going to talk about backdoor stores in a
minute and you can like I could every
time a new iteration starts I could like
feed another another snippet of the Lang
chain documentation in there to get more
more input into the model and more more
knowledge into the model and so
refine the the structure even more and
yeah or you can could integrate an agent
which I'm going to talk about as well
okay
then this was everything about chains
back to the presentation
okay yeah Vector Stores
um does everyone know what a vector
store is
I think we're in a good environment for
that okay good
um basically what what Lang chain does
it makes the combined combination of
llms and documents very easy with with
their own Vector stores integration and
this is actually my favorite feature of
Lang chain
um and I'm going to show why because
this is basically the the go to
application and this is I think also the
reason why link chain was founded in the
first place because they wanted to do
stuff like that I'm going to show
another example
jumping bag
okay here we go
Okay so
we have some input which is our our
input data and I'm I'm only going to
show this part of the input which are
basically some some questions our
finance department would ask like that's
our arbitrary questions uh which our
finance as a department could ask and
this is basically our oh didn't
want to do that sorry
um yeah and what we do
is we yeah basic here and we we load the
the text oh why doesn't it work love it
okay now it works thank God got nervous
um okay and then we split them into into
chunks and we we embed them like in a
vector embedding and it doesn't work
again now it works
um I don't know what's wrong believe me
and uh yeah we embed them using the open
AI API and then we load them into a a
vector start with using pickle you could
use any Vector storage we use bongodb
for example or you can use pine cone
whatever you like but I think for this
demonstration this pickle dump function
is is just fine
um and then we can of course load it
again create a prompt template like I
like I showed you before
um and uh yeah this is where it gets
interesting basically we we create a
retriever object
um which takes the Other M the chain
type and then the vector storage as a
retriever that's important and then we
can what we can do is we can query the
the vector storage with a similarity
search and and over the llm we can ask
the we can ask the llm questions and it
answers based on the knowledge in the
database and this is like uh I think
what provides the most value in line
chain at least for us it does and I
think that's pretty amazing if it would
work why doesn't it work
I don't know I'm sorry it worked this
morning
I'll try one more time
otherwise I'll move on
does not work
sorry guys
okay then I'll move on I'm sorry
okay
the next thing I want to talk about
um is or our agents and combinations
with tools
um basically what they what agents do is
I shown you chains and I I remember what
agents do by thinking about changes that
are undetermined so if you if you have a
chain then you you know what to do next
but an agent can make the decision on
what to do next and this is from my
opinion pretty amazing and basically
agents are in in this area here right
right here and they they make the
decision on when the llm needs
information from an outside Source or
the llm makes the decision on when it
needs information from the outside
source
um and um I'm gonna show another example
I hope it works this time
okay it's uh it's a pretty short one
okay your agents
again the Imports and then all we have
to do is instantiate another model and
uh we have a tool called math it's it's
the other math and it's basically a a
tool which can do calculations and we
initialize that and then what we do is
we initialize the agent with an llm
and with the agent there are multiple
agents I just use this one here I can
read the documentation if you want to
know everything about the agents it's
not that important right now and then we
ask it how are you and now the
are you serious
uh now it works okay
demonstration error love it okay
moving on
um what the llm should do here is
recognize that this is not a math
question and that it doesn't have to
um to do a calculation and does not have
to to use the tool and it does it
perfectly so it it answers I'm doing
well well thank you so you see how the
agent works and then the next thing is
we ask it what's 100 divided by 25 and
then you see the llm things and it sees
okay I need to calculate this
and it's the action is it uses the math
tool and then it calculates it of course
the alarm could have done it with the
API as well but if you have more complex
calculations or more complex tools like
Google search or there's even a Wolfram
Alpha integration for link chain which
is pretty handy and yeah I just wanted
to make clear how our agent thinks and I
think this example is pretty cool for
that
okay
um
so far about the the features no more
examples today
here we go
okay
I'm going to talk about the example
applications which we use at snox and
which I think are pretty pretty handy
for almost every company which which
sells products or which has data and I
think the most commonly known example is
the personalization which I I've talked
about a little before and it's basically
you have a user on the left side which
has a question like in like in Tech GPT
but the the to the model not only knows
what chat GPT knows but it also knows
what's in your vector database so you
could basically what we did is we we
took our notion for example and we put
it in in the vector storage and then you
do a similarity search
and you can ask questions about the
company or about anything if you have
the data for it and this is quickly
implemented in in Lang chain I think it
took me like three or four days of
course then you have to do front end and
stuff but the the decor application is
pretty pretty fast implemented and it
gives a lot of value more value than I
thought because
if you if you take like we are 120
people and you you make everyone like
two or three percent faster because they
don't have to go through notion every
time they have to find something out
about a company
um that's that's that's a lot of value
and I think that's pretty nice and
pretty simple uh application you can
build with uh with Lang chain
okay
um the second thing uh I I came up with
is a um like a notification system for
customer reviews so everyone that sells
products could use this so basically
what you have as an input is customer
reviews from
Let It Be Amazon or let it be your your
own portal or let it be like via
letters or whatever and you take oh no
that has wouldn't work because you
that's not digital
big brain here
um okay
um
yeah you you take these customer reviews
and you you put them into the vector
storage like I said before you you embed
them using the the openai API and you
put them into a vector storage and then
what you do you you do make some prong
prompts uh on finding out the most
important information you need for for
example here for the product development
team and you summarize it using another
llm which is pretty again pretty basic
but for the for the product development
team it's a huge step because they spend
like
30 of their time are not not 30 let it
be 20 20 of their time looking at
reviews finding out what the next
product should should make better or
what what's the best feature for our
customers which we definitely should
stick to and now they get a weekly
report on what they should implement or
should not Implement in the next product
or what they should
make better with the current product so
I think that's that's pretty cool and
then also with Lang chain this was
pretty pretty easy to to implement
and the last example application which I
have today is a bit more advanced but
um I think it's uh it's again pretty
clear so you you'd have a axle or a CSV
um for example in our use case it's uh
it's an ad report so the performance of
of ads from Facebook for example and you
put them into a data frame pandas data
frame and you have rules for optimizing
ads so we have some
some rules internally how our
Performance Marketing team optimizes ads
and this could be in any channel and
then what we do is we put them into Lang
chain we initialize a pandas data frame
agent which is basically an agent
working with with data frames and there
you can get a lot of information out of
these data frames and what we do is we
extract the kpis like our kpis which we
which you want to track out of the out
of the CSV
and then we use a our rule embeddings
which we put into a vector storage
combined with a chain for for
optimization recommendations
so you get like
um
um when you combine these three things
like the kpis the optimization
recommendations and the rule embeddings
in an llm and you can get action
recommendations so you can like have the
for example uh
make the the ad spend higher on this
product or something like that and then
we have our users
or our performance marketers look over
that and then they they submit it or
they decline it and then we can directly
upload the updated
the updated parameters to to our ad
portal which is again this was a bit
more work than the other two but I think
it's still pretty simple and of course
there's the human in the loop so it's
not automated because it's for us it was
not not possible to do not or for me at
that time because I was alone back then
um yeah but I think it's a pretty pretty
nice thing okay
I'm coming to to the summary
um first I said that the length chain is
a framework which makes the work uh with
with LMS way easier
um the prom templates make Dynamic
prompts uh easier for you and I talked
about chains and uh yeah I told you that
it's they are a wrapper and you can like
add them together and make like these
these chains of of actions and alarm
calls
um I talked about how long chain can
can has this has its own integration
with Vector storages and how you can
leverage that to
for example build an uh building a chat
board and I also talked about how you
can use agents for for decision making
in an LM or like decision making on when
to call different tools and use LINE
chain as a connection to to outside
tools
um out between the alarms and outside
tools if you can say so okay and I
showed you a few use cases but uh
believe me there's a lot more and I
encourage you to to try out Lang chain
and and work with it because firstly
it's it's a lot of fun and secondly it's
it gives you a lot of or many benefits
for you and I think also for your
company
all right thank you that's it from me
[Applause]
all right we now have time for a couple
of questions
um maybe it would be a good idea to
start by switching on the lights
uh I think that looks like a switch
awesome
hi there a lot of people
all right are there any questions in the
room
yes
and just a quick question about this
nearest neighbor approach uh wouldn't
that create a bias towards like
individuals that that don't have a
neighbor because they're they're kind of
individual opinion someone says oh this
product is crap because of X so it would
cluster all the similar opinions and the
to be honest I can't tell you anything
about it because it's
it's implemented in in the United
is it I'm sorry yeah no no it's just
just a hunch I I wouldn't maybe you
couldn't talk to the to the founders or
you can contribute and challenge it
yeah no I don't know if it's just a
hypothesis it could be completely wrong
on my side too yeah never thought about
it I'm sorry
all right are there any more questions
um so do you only lose length chain and
the possibilities in there or did you
also think about like combining an llm
maybe for some other classical method
for example using llm for feature
engineering and then use the features
for a classical machine learning model
later on
um or maybe come basically would be
maybe the same thing but to have a
custom tool for length chain so not only
the Wikipedia tool or calculator tool
that is already provided
can you can build custom tools there is
a class for that and we're definitely
planning on using that
I haven't have not played around with
that because uh yeah I started at smokes
like four and a half months ago and now
at the moment I work on the on the quick
wins and this is uh with with text and
the the campaigns and all the I say
standard llm stuff but my heart like I
said I come from from CV and standard
machine learning and I I spend a lot of
time with pytorch and I I say I I missed
that a bit so definitely planning on on
working on that in the future but
haven't haven't tried it out yet
all right so to our remote viewers there
are no questions on slido yet if you are
a fast hacker then maybe I can get one
more in
uh yeah what was the craziest thing
um this stuff did what you perhaps
didn't expect perhaps why I'm asking
like I think when one employee that also
used such an agent and
the agent because I mean it basically
writes code as well just deleted the
whole folder with all the stuff inside
and it was not revertible so
um what what did you experience there
already I I wrote an integration for our
Amazon API
and I thought I deleted all our PPC
campaigns which is
yeah for for those of you who don't know
Amazon it's a lot of money
um so that was a shock but I I only like
moved them into a separate folder so
that's what the agent did and at this at
this moment I was like okay I get a new
account and I make like a test area and
I think that comes close to the craziest
thing that an agent has done for me so
take care of you when you're working
with agents so
thank you
any more questions in the room
so you talked about these tools and then
the agent would choose depending on the
input like okay now I need to use the
math part can it use multiple Tools in
one query like maybe you ask it like
uh currency conversion question with
math could it like check okay I need to
use math calculate and then ask for like
the Forex
yes exchange rate the the input for the
tools is a list so you can you can give
it multiple tools but sometimes if you
have too many tools then it gets
confused on which tool to use so it's if
you have a clear vision of your
application it's better so you you could
think like okay I'm going to put all the
tools in there why not but
um like if you have a clear vision of
your tool then only use the the tools
you know you you will use but because
otherwise it gets confusing it then it
sometimes doesn't use a tool when it
should use it and yeah
that's basically best practice there
any further questions
this is your last chance
but it's nice to see you guys there
sorry about the lights but then let's
move on to the lightning talks
sorry
[Applause]